when Paul Sciarra a defense policy
analyst at the Center for a New American
Security visited u.s. Navy training
grounds in Monterey California he got a
glimpse of what he believes will be the
battlefield of the future they had 10
drones fighting 10 other drones and a
mock aerial dogfight and then watch them
all here at the same time they basically
just push go everything else is
automated the real next frontier is
swarming swarm on swarm combat it's
cooperative autonomy we have lots of
robots working together to accomplish a
goal the human tell us the swarm 10 or
50 or 100 robots working together go
protect this area and defend it and then
the swarm does that all by itself
what will autonomous weapons mean for
how future wars are waged in the loss of
human lives in armed conflicts that's
the topic of Shari's nubuck army of none
autonomous weapons in the future of war
do you think we're going to see that in
the future these robot battles where no
human is even involved I think the
question is what do we mean by no human
is involved so humans will not be
piloting aircraft or ground vehicles in
the future if we repeal with people
piling in with joysticks we were doing
it wrong
that's not something humans are very
good at actually we know that machines
will be able to do those better than
humans machines are already landing
aircraft better than humans and they fly
commercial aircraft better than humans
that's what we've seen dramatic
improvements in airline safety because I
don't lie on all the planets all their
decisions like deciding whether it's a
good idea to attack an enemy those might
be higher level decisions that we still
want humans to be involved in and that's
really what the debate about autonomous
weapons is though homing torpedoes and
smart missiles are nothing new Shari is
concerned about the next level of
autonomy when machines can act without
any human input he says that the classic
Disney movie Fantasia got it right back
in 1940 The Sorcerer's Apprentice it's
probably one of the first stories of
people outsourcing jobs to automation in
the story of The Sorcerer's Apprentice
played by Mickey in the cartoon Don's
the Sorcerer's hat while his away and B
which is a broomstick to take over his
chores which is carrying pails of water
from the well
to a sister it's a classic example of
actually a failure mode and automation
which is the parentheses improperly
specify the conditions the rule set for
the automation it doesn't specify a stop
condition so just keeps running keeps
running keeps running the broomstick
that's now been enchanted doesn't know
to stop filling the sister and once it's
full of water the Sorcerer's Apprentice
takes a nap dozes off so the apprentice
wakes up it keeps going get turned off
you have a runaway problem runaway
algorithm one way the automated process
in this case there's a bunch of water or
the sorcerer comes back and fixes the
problem now if you have this runaway
Alchemist one of my automated process
and it's a weapon system that could be a
real problem and we've seen this in
other cases in stock trading there was
an infamous incident a couple of years
ago called the nightmare on Wall Street
where a high-frequency trading firm
called Knight Capital Group had a
similar problem run away over them that
a glitch in their system it began making
erroneous trades and the span about 45
minutes it was making enough erroneous
trades at machine speed trading millions
of dollars every second that have
bankrupted this company how should we
think about applying things like neural
networks and deep learning to weaponry
you give out a self-driving car you
couldn't give a self-driving car a very
simple set of rules turn left turn right
go 100 feet turn right again then you're
there in the room oh that's not going to
work because you can't control the
environment you don't know where there
are pedestrians and bicyclists and other
cars so you've got to make it adaptable
and flexible that also means that
sometimes you're going to be surprised
by its behavior and all of this is
really magnified by machine learning
systems that don't follow a simple set
of rules instead they learn from data
and then learn from training over time
and some of these methods like neural
networks are really challenging because
they're very opaque sometimes you look
at something like a neural network and
you want to understand well why did it
take this action there's not a simple
answer to that you know you can't just
go debug the code the way you could for
a simple computer script and you could
say well it says if this then that no
that works don't work that way so it's
maybe harder to try to understand why
it's performing an action even after the
fact that's a real challenge when using
these systems doesn't mean that they
shouldn't be used in all varieties of
settings in our lives but it is a
challenge when we think about
predictability and explain ability and
trying to manage the consequences if
something goes wrong an incident from
shareece experience serving as an Army
Ranger in Iraq brought home the risks of
fully autonomous weaponry a little girl
was sent to scout out her position she
had some goats with her in tow and she
was a sense of the herding goats but is
politically that she was sent out to
check us out she was maybe five or six
she wasn't very sneaky to be honest he
was staring at us and kind of walking a
circle around us and we heard the
chirping of what we later realize was a
radio her calling back our position and
probably telling people how many of us
there were so we watched her and she
watched us as she circle us and
eventually she laughed and it wasn't
long after before some Taliban fighters
came so we took care of them and then
the gunfight that in-soo kind of brought
the whole village out and we had to
leave the position but later we talked
about ten what would we do in a similar
situation something that I could tell
you never came up was shooting this
little girl that was not a topic of
conversation
the reality is under the loss of war it
would have been legal to shoot this
little girl if you programmed a robot to
follow the laws of war perfectly it
would have shot this little girl now in
my mind that's not right it's not right
morally even if it is legal there are
some things in war that might be legal
but are not a moral thing to do how do
we program robots to follow not just the
law but also some of these moral
principles and and that's I think a
pretty clear-cut situation but many
situations in war are morally gray there
are sometimes the sad realities and war
we put you know good young men and women
in situations where there are no right
answers and they have to choose between
various shades of wrong and they have to
make choices and all of those decisions
that would be comfortable letting
machines make both we would think that
they they make the right ones but else
what does it say about us as as humans
on our humanity if we offload the more
responsibilities of those decisions to
machines autonomous weapons also make it
possible for combatants to be thousands
of miles from the battlefield with
sherry sees as an extension of earlier
developments in weapons technology
militaries have always been interested
in using new technology to create more
standoff from the enemy whether its bows
and arrows or cannons or
intercontinental ballistic missiles I
think we're gonna see that trend
continue and we'll see more physical
distance I'm actually less concerned
about that I think that's probably
pretty normal I don't know that that's
gonna lead to a major change in warfare
being good or bad one way or the other
because of how it's been fought I think
them were crucial sort of threshold that
were coming up against with autonomous
weapons is human responsibility for
decisions about killing right now with
drones even if it's a drone operator on
the other side of the globe from the
target that person is still making a
very clear decision to use force it's a
human deciding to launch a missile they
understand the human cost of what
they're doing and we see PTSD from drone
operators that really speaks to this
connection that people have
psychologically if not physically was
what's going on at Imus weapons would
would change that they would bring us to
a point where a human is pushing a
button but they're not really involved
in decision about which specific target
to engage would that lead to war with
fuel restraint and and what would be the
consequences over time is there a
possibility that these weapons could in
some ways make Wars less deadly or maybe
even less common well that is absolutely
one of the arguments is that atomic
weapons could make war more precise and
more humane and save civilian lives and
I don't think that you know really you
can understand this by just looking to
self-driving cars if we lose in America
alone over 30,000 people on the roads
every year you know a tremendous
tremendous loss of life there's no
question that over time as self-driving
cars will get better they'll be able to
save lives and reduce casualties and the
principle is really the same that humans
are not perfect in war humans make
mistakes they they commit war crimes
intentionally humans do bad things
and maybe we could program machines to
do better governments have already
developed weapons with varying levels of
autonomy a landmine is a non intelligent
autonomous weapon then there's the
Israeli harpy a loitering missile that
hangs over a designated area waiting to
strike any target that enters in the US
the Defense Advanced Research Projects
Agency DARPA is a largely responsible
for developing the technology I don't
see any programs in the US military and
at least any public programs elsewhere
by other countries that are designed to
totally build fully autonomous weapons
that would cross this line to delegate
lethal force to machines a lot of things
are going right up to the line programs
that would build all of the building
blocks in place and then at a later date
people might be able to just do a
software patch and take a human
completely out of the equation we're
gonna have to live with the world with
the technology as possible the question
is will they be willing to use it and
the senior defense officials in the
United States that I talked to you made
very clear that the you know for them
the answer was not right now their
intention is not to build autonomous
weapons they intend to keep humans in
the loop but they are cognizant of the
fact that other countries may see it
differently and that if Russia or China
cross this line they start building
autonomous weapons that that could
change the equation for them and that
they might be forced to build them in
response with sophisticated drones
accessible even to hobbyists Shari says
it's no wonder that autonomous weaponry
is already being deployed by non-state
actors we've already started to see this
the Islamic state has been use drones in
Iraq and Syria for attacks for the last
couple of years recently just an
assassination attempt against President
Maduro using a drone reportedly at least
the information coming out is a little
bit sketchy about that attack drones are
already being used for aerial attacks by
non-state groups the question is will
they be able to use them for more
autonomous attacks for researching the
book I wanted to understand how hard
would this be to build an autonomous
weapon yourself in your garage and the
unfortunate answer is it is terrifyingly
possible you know what it took me all
about two minutes online to find a
trained neural network that someone
could
load that has humans as an object
certainly people have already weaponized
drones there was a teenager in
Connecticut a couple years ago to put a
video online of a drone with a gun on it
and then later a drone with a
flamethrower on it actually put up on
YouTube the real trick with the Thomas
weapons is the brains of it and the
software is widely available and you
know the technical know-how to do it is
not that hard so we're gonna have to
live with the world where this
technology is possible and we were
unfortunately likely to see in the
coming years and these small-scale
terrorist attacks using this technology
we've got to be prepared for that shari
says one of the biggest unknowns about
the future of autonomous weaponry is
whether governments will agree to limits
on their use and development the
internet has been relatively successful
in limiting chemical weapons not
completely certainly Bashar al-assad is
still using them in Syria today but most
responsible countries have given them up
worse they've had a much harder time
giving countries to give up nuclear
weapons
well nuclear weapons are much worse by
any reasonable measure but they are also
much more valuable or at least the
threat of them is valuable and that's I
think a challenge with the tunnel's
weapons is the jury is still kind of out
and how valuable they are and how
dangerous they are that's very contested
there's a risk that militaries perceive
them as too valuable to give up pretty
good if they can't verify that others
have also done so the momentum is
towards more robotics more autonomy more
artificial intelligence on the US and
Russia and trying to have all you made
very clear their intent to harness
artificial intelligence from military
game China released a new national
strategy for AI last year the Pentagon
has made artificial intelligence an
autonomy the centerpiece of their
program to revitalize American military
modernization that's something where the
momentum is and then of course we've
seen a a growing movement by scientists
and engineers and by human rights groups
to call for some kind of ban or treaty
to try to stop what some might fear met
could be an arms race in autonomous
weapons
you